Let's go next to our caller from the seven
oh six area code seven oh six.
Uh, what's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Oh, that must be me.
That is you.
All right.
Uh, my name is Mike.
I'm calling from, uh, Georgia.
What's going on, Mike?
All right.
Um, I have one question and, uh, maybe a second
if I have time.
Um, are you aware of this, uh, Bernie Sanders
quote that came from, uh, 20?
I think it was a 2015 interview with NBC where
he was talking about, um, how you don't need
like 23 brands of deodorant or sneakers when
there's children's starving or are you aware
of that quote?
I, you know, it rings a bell, but I honestly,
if you said, if you had just given me the
quote and said, who said it, I don't know
that I would say it was Bernie.
So, I mean, I'm generally aware that, I guess
someone said that, but I don't know for sure
who or, or if it's accurately attributed to
Bernie.
Oh, it was Bernie up.
There was like an interview with, uh, believe
it was nbcs.
Um, Harwood I think is his name.
Okay.
Um, and I was just wondering, you know, he's
gotten a lot of flying for Birdie has in like
libertarian circles.
Um, do you think it's a legitimate criticism
or do you think that there's, you know, something
that's not being said?
I mean, what, so the, the, the crux of, for
someone to say, Americans don't need 23 types
of deodorant when kids in Africa are starving
is sort of like saying, you know, you can't,
you'd better eat, you'd better clean your
entire plate in Boston, Massachusetts because
there are kids in Africa starving, which is,
I understand the sentiment, which is, we know
there are first world problems and then there
are people living in abject poverty and we
should all act thoughtfully to the extent
that we can and be activists for improving
the world for as many people as possible.
I get that, but from strictly speaking, it's,
it's sort of a fallacy in a sense.
I mean that, so it's not how I would make
the case for activism.
Let me put it that way.
Okay.
I can believe that makes sense.
Um, all right, well, uh, second question I
had, um, about, uh, Bernie's a free college,
uh, plan.
Um, I'm a big supporter of Bernie by the way.
This is in no way a criticism of Bernie.
I'm a huge Bernie supporter.
Um, I had a conversation with a libertarian
friend of mine about Bernie Free College plant
and he was talking about how, uh, free college
would control what gets taught in school.
Do you know if that's true?
I cannot imagine how you strongly make that
case.
No, I mean, I'm sure that if you asked exactly
how that would happen, I guess the idea would
be if college is paid through taxation, then
the government can tell the colleges what
they need to teach.
But it's like, I don't believe that that is
what would happen.
And there's the potential for that to already
happened because there are so many schools
that are already funded by state governments,
if not federal.
So it seems like an extremely weak argument
against Bernie's plan, but you'd have to find
out exactly how they imagine it would go down.
Okay.
Yeah.
Cause I've, I've been doing research and I've
been really finding nothing to back that argument
up.
Like I've searched deep in the Internet, I
just, I came up empty.
Yep.
Well, I mean, I'm certainly not a aware of
how you would defend such and such an assertion.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well that's all I had.
Thanks for taking my [inaudible].
Okay.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from you.